deme Sanders went back to his childhood
home in New York to launch his second
run for the White House the underlying
principles of our government will not be
greed hatred and lies the campaign now
over his presidential ambitions never to
be fulfilled but as I see the crisis
gripping the nation exacerbated by a
president unwilling or unable to provide
any kind of credible leadership and the
work that needs to be done to protect
people in this most desperate hour I
cannot in good conscience continued
about the campaign that cannot win and
which would interfere with the important
work required of all of us Iran in 2016
and built a network a support base some
would see a movement oh you're ready for
a political revolution he believed he
could deliver as the fight for the
nomination got underway the oldest man
in the race suffered a heart attack
you think he returns to campaigning a
short time later insisting there was no
long term issue but he suffered
disappointment in the first nominating
contest in the administrative mess that
was the Iowa caucuses Sanders came
second behind relative newcomer former
mayor people boo to judge he won the
next two states but lost in South
Carolina to Joe Biden that seemed to
energize the former vice president's
campaign became momentum endorsements
most importantly supporters on Super
Tuesday Sanders won California but lost
other significant states I think we're
also seen is that there is a natural
limit to Sanders appeal to the
Democratic Party writ large for many it
was the label that Sanders the
independent senator from Vermont
attached to himself I am a Democratic
Socialist and his previous support for
left-wing regimes and communist
dictators caused a media frenzy while he
was talking about that he wasn't pushing
his mess
he lost three more states like 2016 he
little realistic chance of catching the
Democratic frontrunner to continue risk
splitting the party an accusation he
faced four years ago with some claiming
his supporters stayed home effectively
handing the presidency to Donald Trump
his presidential ambitions may be over
but he insists he's committed to
removing the man he describes as the
most dangerous president in American
history Donald Trump must be defeated
and I will do everything in my power to
make that happens Bernie Sanders
believed in universal health care higher
taxes for billionaires and free
university education for a long time he
was considered on the fringes of
America's political debate but believes
his ideas are now mainstream I just
don't consider myself very radical a
most of the positions that I held other
I called are consistent with the
American people one but not enough of
them believed he'd be able to deliver in
the White House Allen Fisher al Jazeera
Washington